there are growing calls for Rich Nations
to compensate poor Nations for the
damages they've suffered as a result of
climate change we became a victim of
something
with which we had nothing to do
often referred to as loss and damage so
what is that
three buckets of work the first is to
reduce carbon emissions the second is to
work out how to pay for adaptation
measures like building sea walls and a
third is this loss and damage issue and
that's stuff that frankly just can't be
adapted to that's the loss of villages
of towns of whole Industries the loss of
language and of cultural identity and
it's that issue that is overshadowing
this Summit
to be honest the answer to that question
is it's as long as a piece of string
it's almost unknowable but I'll give you
one example
Pakistan recently suffered from
devastating floods huge proportions of
its country underwater millions of
people heading into winter with no
shelter no electricity and widespread
health problems now as a result of
water-borne diseases and the president
of Pakistan has recently said the latest
estimate for the cost of recovering from
this damage is 30 billion US Dollars and
this all happened despite our very low
carbon footprints
that's one country in one year and just
one event to the scale of loss and
damage is huge and it runs into the
hundreds potentially of billions maybe
even trillions
well that is the critical and
controversial question because poor
Nations say it's Rich Nations they
invented the combustion engine they got
very wealthy of burning fossil fuels and
they drove the climate crisis the
continent of Africa for example is
responsible for less than four percent
of global carbon emissions and yet it is
the most vulnerable to it but the
problem is that wealthy countries don't
want to admit liability they don't even
want to refer to this issue as a
compensation issue and that is where the
discussions are getting stuck
there's no way of claiming specific
compensation for loss and damage what
there is is an absolute ton of
multilateral Institutions like the UN
the World Health Organization the Red
Cross and so on who will come and help
with disaster relief but poor Nations
say that's part of the problem actually
because it doesn't really address the
specific needs often the aid doesn't
come fast enough and no one is talking
about how to compensate Nations for
non-economic losses like the loss of
culture history and language
[Music]
technically it's been complicated and
fraught you've got the poor Nations
developing nations saying
um we can't just talk about this anymore
it has to happen we have to find the
money and you've got wealthy Nations
dancing on the head of a pin saying
we're very supportive of the idea we can
see how much you're suffering and we're
very sorry for causing climate change
but also at the same time they're trying
to avoid being held responsible or
liable crucially
for historical climate change damages
and any that might happen in the future